hey every payment tonight I'm on a game
laughing you may know me from Avengers
infinity ward's ancestors jr. and a new
movie coming out the one and only Ivan
and this for the game called my top ace
for Pittsburgh I'm feeling top three
things adults say to me that annoy me of
the most number one
you're so cute you why are you so tiny
oh my god you're so sassy top three
things my parents say to me over and
over and over and over number one pick
up your shoes and leave them hey to be
fair
I do leave them on the household number
two is where is your phone yes sadly I
lose my phone a lot but now my mom has
like a chapter device on my phone so I
can never lose it again yeah okay clean
the picture because I baked good every
single day it's like a habit of mine I
bake cupcakes I baked rice krispie
treats
so I leave all the dishes around but I'm
getting better so the top three Chris is
ranked number one probably Chris Pratt
has he's hilarious and he's like
Jurassic Park and world and everything
so that's probably my shame Chris hunt
he plays Thor and it was so cool cuz
when I was filming I saw him like
cutting his hair
and number three sadly it'll have to be
Chris Evan because I couldn't have a
full conversation and I want to get to
know you so we can sit down have some
tea
have a lunch didn't get to know each
other don't take the prisoners top three
super powers I'd love to have in the
real life number one I personally would
love to teleport because IFIF you're in
traffic or something it and your home
you know my number two I looked like hmm
I know I let seemed like they were motek
far far away anything like a super cozy
position I wish you could just like take
it or like what's your mind thinking it
pops up like let's say you really really
want water somewhere like you can't
fighting with water number three this is
not like an iffy if you one because like
sometimes I do and sometimes I don't
I want to read people's minds you know
so let's say like someone's really
having like a sad day and then walk from
that coffee I've read their mind and
they're like I go get them coffee and
they have a better name top three things
I'm most thankful for number one my
whole family I have a lot of family
members I'm not gonna name them all cuz
I'll be here for hours but my whole
family how much it my dog foxy she's the
cutest sweetest animal ever and I love
her so much so that's something I'm it's
three number three would have to be
other Timnath tonight having me today
I've had so much fun and thank you guys
for watching
[Music]
[Applause]